hey whats up guys mkbhd here and in this
HD video we'll be taking a look at
chrome deck which is combination of
tweetdeck which you may have heard of
it's an Adobe AIR application for
Twitter and chrome which happens to be
coming out very popularly right now as
Chrome OS comes out and chrome 9 the
browser beta has been released i did a
detroit on that earlier so there's
really up got a lot of good features
that you can get out of chrome and to
use chrome deck as a web-based
application as opposed to a desktop app
so if i'm ever going to do today are my
top chrome deck tips so to start it all
off chrome deck is available at the link
in the description will you visit the
Chrome Web Store where chrome deck is
actually free to download it goes by the
name tweetdeck but since it's available
in chrome like all this version chrome
deck so you can install from right there
just like a Chrome extension would and
you'll immediately having your new tab
section under apps and you can open
tweetdeck just from right there i'll
call it tweetdeck from now on and boom
if you've ever used tweetdeck you're
pretty much already familiar with and
you will probably already know how to
use chrome deck because it looks exactly
like TweetDeck adding a column just like
in tweetdeck as as simple as you would
expect just hit that arrow up top and
pick a column that you'd like to add
it'll give you a preview of it and you
can hit the add column button in the
blue that's it also moving around those
columns that you've added was actually
really easy for me to figure out all I
did was eventually just grab that bar at
the top of column and drag it to move
and it locked itself into place and that
was pretty simple you can move whatever
column you want wherever you want I
could imagine using something like this
in Chrome OS where everything is
browser-based and just really easy to
figure out so without any further ado
let's take a look at that compose window
up at the top which is a separate
feature and what does this remind you of
yep that's right tweetdeck the thing is
you can't exactly change the colors like
you can in the real version of tweetdeck
but you still have all the same features
as in adding media like I showed you
composing a tweet and having a tweet
counter and also being able to choose
what account to post from like a Twitter
account or a Facebook account or a buzz
account really whatever you want another
tip is that since this is a web-based
application everything that would work
on a regular website will work with
chrome deck so like zooming in for
example if your heart of sight and you
really really need to zoom in you can do
that same thing with printing and all
those other function
full screen they'll all work on Chrome
deck also the URL bar at the top is
empty because it's not a website but you
can still use it to google search when
viewing a tweet which you will probably
doing in tweetdeck you'll have the
options to do a couple of things you'll
be able to reply to a person in a
separate pop out window so you can
actually see their tweet as you reply to
it and you can also you know favorite
their tweet and retweet them direct
message the person and a number of other
things all those things that are
available and I guarantee you the
Twitter client you're using on your
desktop pretty cool oh oh and a little
feature I want to tell you guys about is
infinite scrolling on the home timeline
or any of your timelines just keep on
dragging that click bar down to the
bottom and it'll keep refreshing and
reloading and redrawing and re pulling
all those tweets yeah if you really just
really want to catch up on your timeline
haven't been on Twitter in a while there
you go all right so the last feature
i'll show you guys is viewing Twitter
profiles so for example I want to see
who this guy YouTube is I can go ahead
and click on his name and no draw all
his specs and what lists I have them in
and etc and you can even follow him with
that follow button if you haven't
already so that's pretty cool and to be
expected from an online Twitter client
but yeah those are all the tips I've got
for you today for Chrome deck I hope you
enjoyed hopefully I'll be able to bring
you guys more information about google
chrome and Chrome OS in the near future
as I have applied for the pilot program
to get a Chrome OS notebook that I'll be
able to give you guys a lot more
information on so stay tuned for that
and until next time there's been mkbhd
signing out peace